bueno básicamente ha sido una campaña
que de alguna manera ha sido un
referéndum sobre trump en la primera
línea podríamos decir al mismo tiempo ha
sido también un podríamos decir un
referéndum sobre el sistema democrático
de los eeuu y en este punto es donde es
muy interesante la cantidad de gente que
salió a votar y el número de votos que
ha obtenido bardem al mismo tiempo nos
muestra que es un país que ha quedado
realmente partido prácticamente en dos y
donde una parte de la población
desconfía del estado desconfía de la
democracia desconfía de las
instituciones y tiene una y tiene una
percepción política del otro del
adversario político no como un
adversario sino como un enemigo y esto
ha sido muy fomentado por trump no
empezó a controlar no es el único
político en el mundo de la práctica y ya
existía antes en los eeuu pero sin
embargo es el que lo ha llevado a unos
niveles realmente muy altos muy graves
muy dramáticos para
la política de ese país creo que la
campaña mostró todos estos aspectos y
otros que también se han discutido y que
antes ha explicado antonella y que
explicó usted también y los reportajes
de france 24
y de alguna forma creo que lo que nos
muestran es que esa es una realidad con
la que va a tener que convivir o van a
tener que convivir maiden y harris y le
va a ser muy difícil va a ser una va a
tener que gobernar con una situación
inmensamente complicada muy poco cómoda
y con una oposición muy dura no solo en
el congreso en las dos cámaras del
congreso sino también en las redes
sociales del mismo presidente trump que
aunque dejará de ser presidente seguirá
tratando de ser una figura pública o sea
que va a ser bien en cuatro años de gran
complejidad